dear to all the boys fans
an era has come to an end but that
doesn't mean we can't make the most of
it
the third thcb movie has finally hit
netflix and we're taking in
all the lara jean and peter k we can
including behind the scenes moments
ready to find out what scene was being
filmed when lana knew she left noah for
real
or how one of the most adorable moments
in the film was actually
unscripted i love you always forever
what a lot of people don't know about to
all the boys always and forever is that
it was filmed
almost two years ago now so while we had
to say goodbye in 2021
cass said goodbye to one another back in
2019.
it was actually all shot at the same
time as ps i still love you
netflix knew how iconic all the actors
had become and wanted to make sure
everyone was available for the last film
it worked out considering how always and
forever picks up almost
immediately after the last one this is
going on four years of working together
like a lot of movies always and forever
needed some reshoots but thanks to the
global pandemic
those were put on the back burner the
leading lady and man only returned for
reshoots in vancouver more than a year
later
noah even joked that it had been so long
he wasn't sure he knew how to act
anymore
i've not been on a set in about a year
i hope i remember how to act but we got
some adorable pictures of lana and noah
roaming the city because of it so
we're not complaining we're not exactly
sure what they were reshooting but maybe
we can spot a scene in the films where
they look a little older
is where it all started the pandemic
didn't just push back reshoots
it also eliminated every possibility of
having a premiere for the final film
not even the cast could watch their
chemistry come to life together one more
time
instead lana and noah had their own
private premiere over facetime where
they got to watch the first cut
we're pretty sure that must have been
bittersweet for them but we're glad they
had that special moment
even if it was through a screen talking
on the facetime with you yeah oh my god
it was brutal to all the boys maybe a
rom-com but behind the scenes
it's just comedy the prank master
according to anna cathcart and janelle
parrish
it's noah centennial and ross butler i
never have scenes with noah but i feel
like he would be a prankster
i was going to say if anyone would
definitely be no one ross but noah says
his target was always
lana i think i just scared lana i like
to scare her that was my those were my
pranks
madeline gave us the real truth on the
set of the third film the cast had a
game going that if someone winked at you
you would slowly have to start making
your way to the ground until someone
tapped you
unsurprisingly raw says it was always
noah who started it
of course noah would choose that time to
like
sometimes we wonder how they managed to
shoot three films so quickly with how
hilarious this cast is
ross butler has a hidden talent that
snuck its way into the third film
improvising he would apparently have the
cast breaking out into laughter because
of his unscripted one-liners
he like hits you with one-liners over
and over and over again you have no idea
what's coming next and then you just
laugh
but that's not all madeleine also spoke
about ross's improvisation during the
magical prom
scene in always in forever we were gonna
do this kind of plain simple tango and
he went oh no
you've got to do something better
because he is a dancer
not only did they perform an elaborate
tango choreographed by jordan fisher
ross thought it would be cool to get
down and pull out some of his break
dancing tricks
i have two moves left in my arsenal and
those are the two moves you see there
and you will only see those two moves
whenever i dance
by watching them on the screen you would
have never guessed but lana and noah
actually had a pretty awkward first
meeting it was during noah's chemistry
test and he really wanted to run some
lines
so he decided to introduce himself to
lana and ask if she'd be interested
but what he didn't know was that she had
already gotten the part
it wasn't her audition listen to noah
recount her hilarious but
really awkward response and so i'm like
hey do you want to
would you maybe want to run lines and
she was like nah i'm okay
that of course changed very quickly now
after filming three movies the two are
basically inseparable best friends
do you really mean that not a word
speaking of them being closer than ever
the moment lana realized how much she
actually loved noah as a friend of
course
was while they were filming a scene for
the third movie according to the love
letter lana wrote as a goodbye to noah
the scene was in a car and made her
realize how kind and good he is
can you hear our hearts melting to all
the boys author jenny han
also said that the same car scene is one
of her favorites in the film
because of lana and noah's chemistry
i choose you peter kavinsky
the cast spent some time filming in the
big apple for the third film
and even got one of the city's most
well-known attractions to play a part in
the movie
the empire state building lit up in the
classic to all the boys colors
pink yellow and blue it was the backdrop
to the movie rooftop party and you can
actually see it in the film
fell in love with this city
lara jean loves to bake lana condor not
so
much in fact it's not exactly the
actress's forte
which means it was kind of strange to
get lana baking
properly for a scene she had to have a
professional baker next to her at all
times instructing her on what to do
while the cameras were rolling for the
rest of the cast their job was easy
according to noah they just chowed down
on whatever she had baked on set that
day
there are a lot of iconic props from the
tatb franchise
the letters the hat box scrunchies so
what did the cast
actually get to take home with them anna
cathcart says
i got to take my feminist necklace that
kitty wears in all three films
but she's too scared of losing it to
wear it in real life
noah on the other hand took three books
from the set of the final movie
um you know there's there's a certain
book in the third film that has
a little bit of gravity so i took three
of those
a button down and the back of his
actor's chair
there's a moment in the nyc cupcake shop
between lara jean and peter that's
completely unscripted
spoiler if you haven't seen the film yet
lara jean reveals that she wasn't
accepted into stanford
that peter reassures her their
relationship will still be fine
according to jenny han there were
multiple moments in that scene that
weren't in the script
it was just lana and noah being
themselves
[Laughter]
we've been obsessed with lara jean's
wardrobe since the first film
and according to costume designer
lorraine carson it's so easy to add some
of the to all the boys pieces to our
closets
for the third film the majority of her
clothes are from stores like forever 21
and oricia however there are some pieces
that were thrifted
and are authentically vintage shopping
spree anyone
they have to wear it they have to feel
those characters
like we mentioned before the cast got to
fly to nyc for the shooting of their
grad
trip but it wasn't just a vacation for
their characters according to madeleine
the cast spent their time in between
shooting having sleepovers movie nights
and touring the city
they apparently grew even closer than
they were before
their offset time was fun but that
doesn't mean their odds that time wasn't
do you know the iconic pink couch scene
in the nyc subway
well the cast actually had to lug the
couch through a full station of real
commuters for that scene
the train part was filmed on an
abandoned subway line
[Music]
filming in korea is pretty special but
what happened between the cast and korea
is even more spectacular
they explained that it was a huge
vacation for them and basically a
farewell trip
they spent their time shopping for
korean skincare products candy
and eating dumplings tubs of korean
candy
hugs south korea is where they actually
rapped even though it's the first scene
of the movie
in honor of the covey sisters they
locked a lock on the nam sang tower
together
we don't blame lana for crying as soon
as they called cut
we're kind of crying we may have had to
close a chapter on this
love letter but we're glad it came with
all these behind the scenes moments that
make lara jean and peter kay's love
story that much better
the cast has come so far since first
meeting in 2017
and without their off-screen love we
probably wouldn't have gotten the
franchise we
have today let us know what your
favorite behind the scenes moment was
below
and we'll catch you in another video
always and forever
the things